[Music]  [Applause]  this war was a lie  years of blood just delight the fuse of  a secret war  decades in the making  [Music]  my fellow americans a nuclear conflict  would well be mankind's last  we want to make this a more peaceful  world  five days ago we acquired intel  soviet agent perseus is in play  if he's active something big is gonna  happen something that could shift the  balance of the cold war  let's go find this [ __ ]  is the threat real  yes sir we believe it is give mr adler  whatever he wants  [Music]  this one's part of the plan  i know you won't fail us  [Music]  pre-order digital copy and get early  access to the open beta and instant  access to the woods operator pack in  modern warfare including warzone  [Music]  [Music]  you